les sports enfin avec cette bonne
nouvelle pour les bordelais alain
giresse leur capitaine reste finalement
chez eux
il n'ira pas à l'étranger roger zabel
sous quel maillot va jouer alain giresse
la saison prochaine donc j'ai un choix à
faire je n'ai pas fait encore mais je ne
sais pas pour le moment je peux pas
répondre parce que ya beaucoup de choses
qui doivent rentrer en ligne de compte
alors j'attends quand on peut ça c'était
il ya deux jours la réponse nébuleuse
d'alain giresse a tiré roland lors des
trophées antenne 2 alain giresse
récompensé par francis cabrel a
désormais levé le voile sur sa décision
ce matin le milieu de terrain bordelais
convoités comme platini par les clubs
italiens après son étincelante coupe du
monde
alain giresse a resigné pour trois ans
et contrat le liant aux girondins de
bordeaux le capitaine bordelais semble
satisfait de rester en aquitaine même
s'il a été confronté à un dilemme
particulièrement difficile que j'avais
deux possibilités c'était de aux deux de
partir à l'étranger ou de rester la
journée l'étranger c'est bon c'était
notamment jeudi c'était notamment
l'italie mais je dis qu'il y avait
d'autres pays aussi mais bon ils avaient
des arguments qu'ils étaient tout autres
que c'est léger rohner et qu'ils étaient
donc pas négligeable je crois que c'est
un choix
cgg trancher je trancherai pour les
girondins je suis je suis libéré je suis
content si j'étais parti pour étrangers
vrai dit il
il ne parle que pour l'argent et cetera
si je reste monde ira bien autre chose
de toute façon c'est pas c'est pas
important je pense que moi j'ai juste
maintenant tranquille je crois que j'ai
fait mon choix et je crois que je
regrette a pas surtout je suis choquée
rien du tout je suis très libéré
maintenant je crois que je suis content
d'avoir fait ce choix